today we're talking about cloud function
security and where to store things i'm
bikola and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
cloud functions is a lightweight
platform for creating standalone
functions which is a great way to create
pieces of a larger workflow
with the newly launched ability to
specify the minimum number of instances
you no longer need to worry about cold
starts delaying your workflows
try it out for yourself with a linked
tutorial
speaking of cloud functions did you know
it now has native integration with
secret manager
secret manager is a fully managed
storage system for keeping secrets like
api keys or passwords
these two great services are even better
together so check out how you can get
better at keeping a secret
the sooner you think about security the
less downstream issues you're likely to
have
that is why it can help to have an
on-demand scanning setup as part of your
cicd process
you can read more about how on-demand
scanning can help detect vulnerabilities
in containers and follow along in
tutorials to stay secure
while you may not be able to move all
those boxes and garage to cloud storage
it's a perfect solution for object
storage no matter what your application
needs
if you're not sure which storage class
or location to use don't worry priyanka
breaks it down in this quick sketch note
and blog post if you want to read about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or idea
leave a comment or tweet us and we'll
see you in the cloud
you